l'été c'est la saison des chantiers de
restauration des monuments historiques
et en saône et loire l'association
rempart s'occupe de plusieurs chantiers
dont celui de l'église saint-pierre à
senozan reportage de damien boutier
robin wright et pierre laporte de
vraiment reconstruire une restauratrice
qu'il faut faire de l'effet est de
connaître de découvrir cette coupe
plus qu'une découverte c'est une
véritable transmission des savoirs
qu'opère la restauratrice professionnels
qui encadrent le stage car ici le
promise à sion étape ce sera très
compliqué d'expliquer simplement il faut
toujours passer derrière pour voir
comment c'est perçu comment le
commandant comment la construire est
perçu et puis le coup de pinceau quoi là
où on l'a lu et effectivement dans les
détails de la fin des travaux
parfois il faut savoir le manipuler ou
en général j'ai quand même des bénévoles
qui sont joints à d'autres travaillent
aux teintes chaudes me fit un bien mis
fin on ne peut pas être vraiment très
près du mur nous qu'il faut garder qu'un
une certaine distance sont revenus sains
et le pinceau il faut que les jeunes
apprécient pas gérer les deux qu'on la
hauteur et le pinceau et subtilement eu
sur rodage mais pas fier pour ne pas
abîmer le mur de quoi désorienter
avant je travaillais plus tôt sur les
pulsions de chevalet dans la
restauration c'est hélas tu es sûr que
tu as complètement différent où les
lions du coup sûr un support pas du tout
jetable mais après j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses
sur la technique à la chaussure le
travail en chantier même chose depuis
2006 un peu d'idées gif et tous les ans
objet d'un chantier de rénovation encore
de cession et elle retrouvera totalement
son lustre d'antan